so we're about to go to the Meetup I
called a meet up the Iraqi could show
some of the content that I put out quick
it's gonna be it's gonna be 20 people so
like I'm literally just gonna be like
I'm gonna watch during the street
[Applause]
perfect let's do it
so um this is what I do I'm sure d-roc
picks this up a lot I just rub my left
glute on sharp [ __ ] all the time it
makes me feel better
I've got some [ __ ] going on there I
stretch I roll I got the ball I got the
look it what I don't know what they call
it it's at every gym that kind of like
the Tootsie Roll thing rolling that I
got the ball across ball I stretch a
yoga it's getting better it was a
disaster two years ago just utter
disaster it's getting better tomorrow is
the big vein or world event which will
be great which I'm really looking
forward to
and just having some great business
meetings a lot of agency stuff spoke at
an amazing all-time great agency
I sit on panels and all these fancy
[ __ ] places now a nai RR if I can can
write and I listen to people and I get
to know them because we have a you know
we're in the green room together for
coffee for an hour before the panel and
then eventually you're out at the
[ __ ] Facebook pardon you see that
person you get a drink and it's blown me
away how many of these people when you
get a couple of cocktails into them say
to me things like Gary you're right how
many of you saw the big short the movie
raise your hands I'm just curious I
swear to God when I watched that movie I
was like holy [ __ ] this is the
advertising industry everybody knows it
and everybody's in on it there's me I
mean what I'm looking around the room
this is not 80 year old white men I mean
this is like like all of you know yeah
um I mean there's nothing else that
matters to me like that's why I've bring
up to Big Short because like everybody
knew on Wall Street it's funny like I
just watched the big show on Sunday and
I was like um halfway through a
beautiful day in London everybody's
commenting I said that the rock brought
the good weather a not caught on film
d-roc tried to use the wrong pass at the
train station not a very good traveler
between the miss flight in Australia and
holding me up at the train station
because you literally used a different
pass do you reckon you could talk you're
a big boy your hotel room key man just
much love to everybody hope you're
enjoying the series we're enjoying it
it's getting if you know it's becoming
so weird like this has become way too
normal for what I know people I mean the
level of jokes that are happening
between my friends my contemporaries my
acquaintances and definitely my
competitors and and people that don't
like my stuff as much the level of
narcissism around somebody following you
around but I will take all that on
because I'm a big [ __ ] boy I'll take
that all on for the hundreds of emails
from all of you that of emails and say
this is a process that has allowed you
to learn no askgaryvee no white paper on
SlideShare nope
you know it has taught you more than
seeing it seeing it and and so that that
one email from all the 18 year olds and
44 year old you guys know who you are
those emails those comments that oxygen
trumps all the stuff that I know is
going on around me but to the point it's
getting weird how normal this has become
Dirac like I've really toned you the
[ __ ] out it's making it cool it's making
a cool so good talk today this morning
too it's fun to be there so let's go
back to work you're right London 10:00
p.m. start tonight I've decided 10:00
p.m. so Howe area more detail to come
the plant literally nobody knows I don't
know we just do as much of it's big yeah
is that true yeah
all right London Soho Square Gardens on
the corner of soho and print right
oh no yes
I was scary feeling this we've been
getting some snaps that make us feel
like there would be a little bit more
London I'm humbled I love you
create some clarity about tonight yes
just the park is gonna be closed we're
just gonna beat outside the rock you
didn't need to look at what I just saw
[ __ ] Jesus Christ all right this is
gonna end up a little bit bigger than we
thought
[ __ ] me thanks for being here
[Applause]
all right I started seeing way too much
chatter of like people not being able to
make anything maybe we'll meet like 20
or 30 people in the corner kind of
misjudged it a little bit you know
what's up guys my name is Daniel then he
I do freestyle football and I also make
music I do like hip-hop beats and stuff
I rock has actually used some money some
Gary's videos before I just want to say
thanks to Gary for coming out here he's
been so like generous with his time and
just making sure he signs every book
takes every picture thanks a lot and
yeah if you guys want to carry these
things might love you any social media
strategies for six years so love the
character
to me I look at losing as a positive
mainly because everybody here doesn't
like losing cuz they're worried what
other people think about their loss
program I don't give a [ __ ] about what
other people think about my L it's my l
you go worry about yourself I got this
is my L and the reason people don't like
losses is not so much the data like
losses they're worried about what
everybody else thinks about their loss
that's the [ __ ] gear
so much positive emotional intelligence
and self-awareness you know what I ride
with carry energy works so Lonnie I hope
one day
you know I hate giving advice that I
don't know like self-awareness I don't
want to teach you self-awareness like I
don't I don't know how I got gratitude
it just happened like me I'm in tune
with my feelings I don't think I figured
that out it wasn't like there was no
nine step process to get into my
feelings I'm just into my feelings and
so because I'm into my feelings I know
how thankful I am I know how lucky I am
guys I if some of you have heard me say
this before now rare it is to become a
human like what do I mean I mean the
math around actually becoming a human
being is [ __ ] insane like you've won
you did it you did it and so like I
think about [ __ ] like that I think about
[ __ ] like what if my family died like I
think about what I actually care about
and it makes me happy
you know everybody's grateful for
different things I'm grateful for health
and then I'm grateful for the talents I
was given it's easy for me to be
grateful just like it's easy for a lot
of you to look at the negative I have
negative people my life five negative
family members like they look at
something that's a negative I just don't
know that gear I don't [ __ ] give
negativity or my losses the respect I
don't think I don't respect it yeah man
when girlfriend's paced by his weapon
I'm sorry
Victoria Victoria I'm sorry this is a
one-time thing he's with you every night
thanks Stu anyone hi how you been how
long ago was that God we did a meet-up
in September there was like seven people
there she can change quick yeah who
knows how you doing
thanks for waiting so ask away reelers
what do you want to know see you
tomorrow
I really appreciate I wish I had a
question for you babysitting the enemy
listening tomorrow everything I know you
got a fire I'm feeling you I've seen
people you attend they've known you from
Wine Library I haven't and
you lost six months yes don't get
nothing look man it's clear I really
appreciate that thank you brother I
appreciate that I look forward to
following you me too man thank you for
hanging out for so long tonight thank
you jesus [ __ ] christ wasn't dirty
was not there was not thirty I lost that
bad you weren't you weren't right either
he's at 50 we're people walking by like
what the [ __ ] what do you say
absolutely
what you gonna do with you